now when you have bugo winning three
million dollars at a fortnight
tournament how is a parent walking
around Earth right now not realizing at
least giving their child a chance to
show that they're great at video games
is is no different than them showing
that they're great at rugby or proper
soccer or golf listen to your kids and
when I say listening watch them what do
they gravitate towards nobody thought
playing video games 20 years ago was
going to lead to a luxurious Financial
life it clearly has if you want your
kids to be successful recognize that the
world you live in today has nothing to
do with the world they're going to live
in